[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء تبنى الحوثيون
اختطاف احمد عوض بن مبارك مدير مكتب رئيس
الجمهوريه اليمنيه والامين العام لمؤتمر
الحوار الوطني واعتبروا هذا الاجراء خطوه
اضطراريه لق الطريق امام اي محاوله انقلاب
على اتفاق السلم والشراكه ولوقف تمرير ما
وصفوها بمخالفات في مسوده الدستور اليمني
الجديد نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي حقيقه المخالفات في مسوده
الدستور اليمني والتي دفعت الحوثيين
لاختطاف مدير مكتب رئيس
الجمهوريه وما هي التداعيات المحتمله
لاستمرار الخلاف على مسوده الدستور على
الاوضاع السياسيه والامنيه في
[موسيقى]
اليمن اذا طالبت جماعه الحوثي الرئيس
اليمني منصور هادي بان يدرك حساسيه الوضع
حتى لا يكون مظله لما دعتها قوى الفساد
والاجرام وحذرت من اجراءات ستقوم بها
اللجان الشعبيه ضد هذه القوى جاء ذلك بعد
تبني الحوثيين اختطاف احمد عوض بن مبارك
مدير مكتب رئيس الجمهوريه والامين العام
لمؤتمر الحوار الوطني قبيل تسليمه مسوده
الدستور الجديد للبلاد لهيئه الرقابه على
تنفيذ مخرجات الحوار الوطني وقد انسحب
ممثلوا المؤتمر الشعبي مع الحوثيين من
اجتماع هيئه الرقابه على مخرجات الحوار
معترضين على مساعي تمرير مسوده
الدستور لم يعجبهم شكل الدوله فخطف وه
هكذا انتهى الحال بمدير مكتب الرئاسه
اليمنيه رهينه بين ايدي الحوثيين وهو في
طريقه الى اجتماع في الرئاسه وبيده مسوده
دستور لا يوافقون عليها احمد عوض بن مبارك
ابن الجنوب الذي يشغل ايضا منصب الامين
العام لمؤتمر الحوار الوطني وكان مرشحا
سابقا لرئاسه الحكومه استبعد بعد اعتراضهم
فكل شيء يتصل بالسلطه في اليمن بات واقعا
تحت اراده الحوثيين ويسير على وقع بنادقهم
منذ استولى على العاصمه صنعاء بالسلاح
واستباحوا فيما يسمونها ثوره سبتمبر
2014 تزامنا مع الخطف انسحب ممثلوهم من
اجتماع الرئيس عبد ربو منصور هادي ومعهم
ممثلو حزب الرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله
صالح المؤتمر الشعبي العام كان الاجتماع
مقررا لتسلم مسوده الدستور الجديد ساعات
ثم تبنت الجماعه خطف عوض في بيان قالت فيه
انه جاء ردا على ط مبدا التوافق الذي تم
اقراره عند توقيع اتفاق السلم والشراكه
ووصف البيان مسوده الدستور او شكل الدوله
كما قالوا التي كان يحملها عوض بانها
احاديه وتوافق ايرادات خارجيه وتخالف
مخرجات مؤتمر الحوار لذلك اوقفته اللجان
الشعبيه وهو الاسم الذي يطلقونه على
الميليشيات المنتشره في الشوارع لقطع
الطريق على ما دعاه بيان الحوثي الانقلاب
على اتفاق الشرا
وبنبره تهديد يلوح بيان الحوثيين باجراءات
خاصه ستقوم بها اللجان الشعبيه حتى ترعوي
تلك القوى وغيرها وان على الرئيس اليمني
ان يدرك حساسيه الوضع حتى لا يكون مظله
لقوى الفساد والاجرام وفق البيان هكذا
يدخل الرئيس نفسه في مرمى التهديد الحوثي
بما يرى معه كثيرون عبثا خالصا في الخوض
بمسار سياسي والدوله نفسها
رهينه السلاح ابرز نقاط الاختلاف بشان
الدستور تقسيم اليمن الى اتحاد فيدرالي من
سته اقاليم يرفض الحوثيون وصالح وقبائل
داعمه له هذه التقسيمات في مقابل هذا
الضجيج في العاصمه يتواصل صراع عسكري
مفتوح في مناطق اخرى اهمها مارب بين
الحوثيين والقاعده ورجال القبائل هناك على
الارض لا دوله ولا شكل لها بل توازنات
تكتبها لغه واحده يفهمها الجميع
السلاح موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفنا من
صنعاء علي الفقيه رئيس تحرير صحيفه المصدر
المستقله مرحبا بك سيد علي
و ابدا معك من البيان الذي صدر عن اللجان
الشعبيه والذي يشير بالتفصيل الى ما
اعتبره مخالفات في تنفيذ اتفاق السلم والش
شراكه ومخالفات ايضا فيما تم الاتفاق عليه
بشان اي ان تكون مسوده الدستور متوافق
عليها ايضا ولهذا السبب جرى هذا الاختطاف
ما رايك بهذه الاسباب التي وردت في بيان
اللجان
الشعبيه اعتقد ان هذه الاسباب قد يعني
مورست تحت هذا او تحت هذه اللافته كثير من
الاعمال المخله
وال المحرمه والممنوعه قانونا ودستورا
وحتى بما يتعلق بالاعراف اليمنيه فنسمع
دوما ان الحوثيين يبررون اعمالهم بمخالفه
اتفاق والسلم والشراكه بمخالفه نتائج
محتمل الحوار الوطني ب يعني امور قد يمكن
التفاهم حولها او النقاش حولها لكن
الاشكال انهم يلصقون تحت هذه العناوين
جرائم واعمال كبيره ليس اكبرها الاختطاف
وما جرى اليوم اليوم من اختطاف مدير مكتب
رئاسه الجمهوريه وهو مسؤول كبير في الدوله
لم يكن احد يتوقع ان يصل الامر الى هذه
الدرجه هو امتداد لعمليه الاختطاف
والتفجير والقتل التي تمارسها الجماعه
والتي وسلوك القوه التي تنتهجه على الارض
اليمنيه فهي تجتاح محافظات وتستولي على
مدن تحت عنوان تنفيذ اتفاق السلم والشراكه
وكان الجماعه تفهم هذا الاتفاق عكس ما
يفهمه كل الناس الاتفاق نص على على بنود
واضحه وكان هناك امور يعني يعني فهمها
الجميع من ضمنها انجاز الدستور كان لدى
الحوثيين اعتراض على شكل الدوله او ما
يتعلق بتقسيم اليمن الى سته اقاليم
وبالتالي يمكن ان نتفهم هذا الاعتراض
ويمكن النقاش معهم يمكنهم ان يرفضوا
الدستور لكن ما ليس مفهوما هو ان تبادر
هذه الجماعه الى ممارسه عمليه الاختطاف
وهو سلوك عصابات وليس سلوك جماعات سياسيه
يصعب علينا فحد جماعه الحوث عن سيدي
الفقيه هذه النقطه بالتحديد اريد ان اتوجه
بها الى عضو المجلس السياسي لجماعه انصار
الله الحوثيين علي لحوم معنا عبر الهاتف
من صعده سيد علي يعني ربما من حق جماعه
انصار الله ان تعترض وان تقول انها ترفض
مسوده الدستور وتتحدث عن مخالفات لاتفاق
السلم والشراكه ولكن هل يحق لها ان تصل
الامور بها الى اختطاف شخص مثل احمد عوض
بن مبارك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا في البدايه
الاخ عوض احمد بن مبارك هو لم يتم اختطافه
بل تم توقيفهم من قبل اللجان الشعبيه
ولذلك هناك اسباب كثيره جدا يعني الجانب
الرسمي وكذلك بعض القوى السياسيه اليوم
زالت ترفض تنفيذ اتفاق السلم والشراكه
الوطنيه وهناك اختلالات كثيره وهناك
محاوله لتمرير مشروع الاقاليم السته
ومحاوله لفرض هذا المشروع الذي رفضناه
سابقا ولا زلنا نرفضه حتى اليوم ولذلك هو
تم توقيفه واللجان الشعبيه هي تدخلت اليوم
في هذا الموقف من اجل ان لا يكون هناك
انقلاب على اتفاق السلم والشراكه الوطنيه
حيث ينص هذا هذا الاتفاق وهناك بنود واضحه
في الاتفاق بان موضوع الاقاليم وشكل
الدوله يعود الى الهيئه الوطنيه وان
الهيئه الوطنيه هي من تعالج شكل الدوله
لكن نفاجا بان الجانب الرسمي ل
ينظر بعين الاعتبار الى المطالب التي
نتحدث بها حتى كذلك الحراك الشعبي الموجود
اليوم في الشارع وكذلك يعني لم نرى الجديه
في الجانب الرسمي ولا من بعض القو
السياسيه هل استنفذت كل الوسائل كل وسائل
الاعتراض حتى يصل الامر الى الاختطاف او
ما تسميه توقيف احمد عوض بن مبارك لم يعد
هناك اي سبيل اخر باستثناء هذه الوسيله
لكي تعطلوا اي مسوده الدستور او تمرير
مسوده
الدستور نعم عملنا على وسائل كثيره جدا
كان هناك تواصلا مع رئاسه الجمهوريه كذلك
مع بقيه المكونات السياسيه يا اخوان هناك
محاوله للانقلاب على اتفاق السلم والشراكه
الوطنيه بعيدا عن المكايدات السياسيه
بعيدا عن المهاترات هناك واقع لابد ان
نتحرك بمسؤوليه امام هذا الواقع هناك
محاوله للانقلاب على هذا الاتفاق ولكن دون
جدوى الجانب الرسمي لن ينظر الى كل نطالب
به وكلما نتحرك به في
الطرق يعني المتاحه ينظر اليها بعين
الاعتبار فكان موقف اللجان الشعبيه اليوم
هو
موقد للحيلوله دون ان يكون هناك انقلاب
على اتفاق السلم والشراكه الوطنيه سيما
وان انه اليوم كان هناك محاوله لتمرير ذلك
المشروع الذي نعتبره مشروعا خارجيا لا
يخدم البلد سيد علي لم يعد هناك من سيد
علي الفقيه لم يعد هناك من
امكانيه ل
توقيف تمرير مسوده الدستور الا بهذه
الطريقه لم يسمع احد من الحوثيين من انصار
الله موقفهم ولم يستجب احد لهم حتى الحراك
الشعبي ما
رايك اعتقد انه امر يدعو الى الضحك انه
ليس
هناك يعني وسيله للاعتراض على الدستور سوى
الاختطاف يا انا اعتقد انه هذه الجماعه
غير قادره على النزول الى المجال العمل
السياسي فهي تمارس سلوك العصابه الاختطاف
يا اخواننا سلوك عصابه وليس سلوك جماعه
تدعي ممارسه العمل السياسي العمل السياسي
يتيح لك الرفض عن طريق الاحتجاج عن طريق
التظاهر عن طريق الاعتراض عن طريق رفض
تمرير تمرير الدستور شعبيا لا يزال
الدستور لا يزال مسده هو هو يقول انه كان
سيتم تمرير المسوده باي طريقه من الطرق
وهذه كانت الساعات الاخيره اليوم كان
ستسلم مسوده الدستور فبالتالي لم يتم لا
يمكن ايقاف هذا الامر الا بهذه
الطريقه لا لا ليس صحيحا الدستور سيسلم
لهيئه الرقابه على تنفيذ مخرجات الحوار
وسيوضع للنقاش الشعبي مبدئيا وبعد ذلك
سيمر بمراحل عده ستناقش سيناقش على
المستوى الشعبي وستناقش القوى السياسيه
وسيوضع مؤخرا للاستفتاء في مرحله لاحقه
عندما توافق الناس على هذه المسوده لكن
اللجوء الى هذه الوسيله وبطريقه سريعه
وبفرض القوه
واختطاف مدير مكتب الرئاسه على اساس انه
كان يحمل الدستور ليس له سوى معنى واحد ان
هذه الجماعه غير قادره على فهم معنى العمل
السياسي وانها فقط تمارس عمل عصابه مسلحه
لديها من القوه ما يمكنها من فرض من فرض
رايها على على الجميع هذا ما تعتقده وهذا
ما تحسبه وبالتالي يدفعها الى احراق
سمعتها سياسيا والى قطع الطريق على نفسها
امام حتى ا الشعب لم يعد يامل في ان تتحول
هذه الجماعه من خلال ممارساتها اليوميه
هناك فقدان للامل ان تتحول الى جماعه
سياسيه تمارس العمل السياسي المدني السلمي
مثلها مثل باق الاب والمجموعات السياسيه
الموجوده على الساحه سيد علي القحوم لماذا
لم
تسلكوا يعني السبل الديمقراطيه في
الاعتراض من خلال مثلا التصويت الشعبي من
خلال الاستفتاء فيما بعد ومن خلال القنوات
السياسيه التي تشاركون فيها بالنهايه هناك
يعني مستشارون
للرئيس منصور هادي من
الحوثيين اخي العزيز نحن عملنا ما بوسعنا
وتحركنا باكثر من موقف وكان هناك بيانات
واضحه بخصوص هذه المواجه لكن للاسف ضيفكم
الكريم هو يحاول ان يظلل ويكذب حتى ويفتري
وهو يدرك في نفسه انه يكذب الواقع في
اليمن هو يعرف ما
معنى اليوم في البلد وما كانت جماع ما
كانت تمارسه في 2011 والحا وما كانت
تمارسه تلك الجماعات دون ان نرى مثل هذه
الاستنكارات نحن نستطيع ان نعمل عملا
سياسيا لكن في ظل اجواء مهيئه لم لا يكون
فيها يعني الجانب الرسمي وكذلك بعض القوى
السياسيه مرتحله للخارج لا تريد ان تنفذ
اتفاقه سلم والشراكه بل تتبابع وتتلى وذك
ظل هذه الاجواء القادمه فيظل هذه الاجواء
القامه عل حت ندخل في اطار الاتهامات
والالفاظ غير المحبذ في هذا النقاش اريد
ان اسالك اين هي المشكله بالنسبه اليكم
المشكله كما هو معروف في التقسيمات
تقسيمات الاقاليم في مسوده الدستور ما هو
البديل الذي تطرحونه و ما هي رؤيتكم لهذا
ماذا تريدون بالضبط اولا اخي العزيز بخصوص
الاقاليم نحن طالبنا من منذ اليوم الاول
عندما اعلن هذا المشروع لانه مشروع لم
ينبني على رؤيه علميه وكذلك اقتصاديه
ولذلك طالبنا بان تشكل بان يؤكل الموضوع
الى لجنه لجنه متخصصه تدرس الوضع يعني ليس
لدينا مشكله في شكل الدوله الدوله نحن
اتفقنا في مؤتمر الحوار الوطني بان تكون
دوله اتحاديه لكن ان ياتي التقسيم بهذه
الطريقه الذي يخدم كان مراكز القوى في تلك
المرحله وكذلك يخدم الخارج ونحن راينا انه
تقسيما سياسيا يستهدف البلد كل البلد دون
دون النظر الى المعايير التي ينبني عليها
هذا مشروع ولذلك طالبنا مطلب يعني محق
ومشروع بان يوكل هذا الموضوع الى لجنه
متخصصه تراعي المعايير العلميه وكذلك
الاقتصاديه نعم ابقى معي السيد علي لحوم
وايضا سيد علي الفقيه من صنعاء مشاهدينا
فاصل قصير نناقش بعده التداعيات المحتمله
لاستمرار الخلاف على مسوده الدستور هذه
التداعيات على الاوضاع السياسيه والامنيه
في اليمن في ضوء تبني الحوثيين لاختطاف
مدير مكتب رئيس الجمهوريه ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش دلالات تبني الحوثيين
اختطاف مدير مكتب رئيس الجمهوريه اليمني
في ظل خلاف حول مسوده الدستور الجديد
للبلاد و اعود الى ضيفي من صنعاء علي
الفقيه سيد علي ماذا تتوقع من اجراءات
خاصه يهدد تهدد بها اللجان الشعبيه في
بيانها حتى ترعوي كما يقول البيان قوى
الفساد عن غيها وتتوقف عن ممارساتها
الاجراميه كما تقول بحق الشعب حاضرا
ومستقبلا وتقول ان على الرئيس هادي ان
يدرك حساسيه الوضع حتى لا يكون مظله لقوى
الفساد والاجرام ماذا يعني لك هذا
الكلام في البدايه اود ان اقول لاخي علي
القحوم انه انا ليس لي جماعه انا جماعتي
هم الصحفيين الذين يتعرضون للملاحقات
والتهديدات بشكل يومي من قبل الجماعه
نفسها ال اختطفت احمد عوض بن مبارك اما
ماذا نتوقعه فليس بعد اختطاف مدير مكتب
رئاسه الجمهوريه الذي هو رجل دوله بدرجه
نائب رئيس وزراء في البلد سوى ان يتم
اختطاف الرئيس ومستشاريه الذين هم قيادات
الاحزاب في البلد وتكمل الجماعه سيطرتها
على مقاليد الامور يعني هي تاركه الان فقط
مجال لبقاء الرئيس بشكل ديكوري وت رر عبره
وعبر حكومته ما تريد من القرارات سواء ما
تم تمريرها او ما فرضتها بالقوه يعني الان
الوزراء ومدراء المؤسسات سواء الامنيه
والعسكريه او المؤسسات المهمه في في
القطاع المدني لا تستطيع ان تمرر قرارا او
تمرر امرا اداريا الا بموافقه جماعه
الحوثي المسلحه وهم يدركون ذلك جيدا
وبالتالي اعتقد ان تلويح بالتصعيد ليس
معناه سوى استكمال القضاء على ما تبقى من
هذه الديكورات او ما تبقى من مسؤولين او
قيادات سياسيه
يشبهون سيد علي لو كان الحوثيون لو كان
الحوثيون قادرين مثلا على فرض رؤيتهم ربما
لما لما اضطروا الى اللجوء لهذه الوسيله
وكانوا عدلوا مسوده الدستور بما يتوافق
ورؤيتهم يعني ماذا ماذا تتوقع ان ان
يعملوا بعد اختطاف الرجل الذي كان يحمل
مسوده الدستور هم الان اختطف الدستور بكله
يعني وبالتالي وجود الرئيس وسلطه الرئيس
وسلطه الدوله والقرار السياسي في البلد هو
مختطف لديهم وبالتالي ما تبقى الان هو
مجرد مناورات مجرد بقاء للحوثيين في
التحكم بالامور من خلف الكواليس حتى لا
يتحملون المسؤوليه عن السلبيات امام الشعب
اما القرار السياسي في البلد والقرار
الامني والعسكري فهو مصادر من قبلهم وهذا
يدركه جميع من يعيش في هذا البلد او يتابع
شانه سيد علي
القحوم بماذا تحذرون الرئيس هادي وما هي
الاجراءات الخاصه التي تهدد اجراءات خاصه
اضافيه تهدد اللجان الشعبيه القيام بها هل
الاطاحه بالحكومه وبرئيس اليمني
ايضا اولا اخي العزيز اتفاق السلم
والشراقى الوطنيه هو منجز تاريخي
ومكتسب من مكتسبات الثوره الشعبيه ولذلك
اللجان الشعبيه وابناء الشعب اليمني لن
يقبلوا اي محاوله للانقلاب على هذا
الاتفاق من من من من من اي طرف يكون ولذلك
الرئيس هادي عليه ضغوطات خارجيه ضغوطات
امريكيه سعوديه في عدم تنفيذ اتفاق السلم
والشراكه الوطنيه وهذا هو الواقع وال الاخ
علي هو يتحدث بدون يعني بدون حياديه هو
يتحدث على انه صحفي وكاتب ومتابع لكن لا
ينظر الى الواقع بعين مجرده هو يدلج
ويحاول ان يشوه وان يسوق الاكاذيب وال
التضليلات
سك سالتك سؤالا
واضحا س سيد علي سالتك سؤالا واضحا ما هي
الخطوات المقبله بعد توقيف مدير مكتب
الرئيس ما هي الخطوات المقبله بمواجهه
الرئيس الذي لا يجرؤ كما تقول على مواجهه
الخارج وايضا الاجراءات الخاصه التي
تهددنا بها اعطيني جوابا على هذه النقطه
اولا اخي العزيز الشعب اليمني لن يقبل باي
التفاف على تنفيذ اتفاق السلم وشراك
الوطنيه وهناك الخيارات كثيره جدا ولذلك
لا يحق لمكون سياسي ولا كذلك للرئاسه ول
من تبقى في الجانب الرسمي ان يحاولوا ان
ينقلبوا على اتفاق السلم والشراكه الوطنيه
ولذلك الشعب اليمني سيتحرك بكل الخيارات
التي تمنع من تمرير اي مشروع يستهدف الوطن
كل الوطن لم تجب لم لم تجبني عما عما يمكن
ان ان يحصل فقط اريد منك توضيح من هو
الخارج الذي تقصدون في انه يتم تبني رؤيه
احاديه للدستور ارضاء للخارج ضمن مشروع
يهدف الى تفكيك البلاد من تقصد
بالضبط اولا اخي العزيز عندما تنظر الى
الضخ الاعلامي الكبير والذي يحاول ان يدق
على وتر الطائفيه والمذهبيه والمناطق
وكذلك محاوله الى تفتيت البلد واحياء
النزعات المناطق في محاوله لتقسيم البلد
وتفتيت البلد ومحاوله لتنفيذ السيناريو
العراقي الموجود اليوم في المنطقه ولذلك
عندما انتصرت الثوره الشعبيه ام وسقطت
الايادي التي كانت تعبس بامن واستقرار
البلد ومراكز البو والمجرمين والعملاء
هناك كان هناك مؤامرات كثيره لتسليم ما
يسمى بتنظيم القاعده الكثير من المحافظات
ولنا عبره بما جرى في العدين وكذلك في جبل
الرش في الحديده وحيث ذبح الجنود هناك و
اي ن عل انت لا تريد ان ان توضح اكثر من
ذلك اريد ان ارحب بضيف انضم الينا من
ليفربول الكاتب الباحث السياسي اليمني
محمد جبح مرحبا بك سيد محمد ماذا تتوقع
بعد هذا الاختطاف و بعد التهديد باجراءات
اضافيه جديده يمكن ان تتخذها اللجان
الشعبيه وايضا التحذير الواضح للرئيس
اليمني من قبل اللجان
الشعبيه طبعا انا اتوقع عن ان يصار الى
القضاء على باقي مكونات الدوله ممثله برمز
واقول رمزيه او ديكوريه رئاسه الجمهوريه
لان الحوثيين لم يستبقوا هذه هذا الراس
الا من اجل ان يتمدد من خلاله ومن خلال
اذرع المؤسسه مؤسسات الدوله الى بقيه
الاقاليم والمحافظات حتى يحكموا السيطره
ثم بعد ذلك يكون عبد الرب منصور هادي رئيس
الجمهوريه اخر الاوراق التي ينزعون من
امام مشروعهم هذه جماعه يتحدث ضيفكم من
صنعاء ممثلها عن
مساله تنفيذ الاتفاقات واليمني
لم يعرفوا في تاريخهم المعاصر والقديم
جماعه نكثت بالاتفاقات مثل الحوثيين يقول
ان ان انه يسعى الى عدم تفكيك البلاد
والعجيب انا عضو مؤتمر الحوار الوطني وكان
الحوثيون يؤيدون الذين يطرحون حق تقرير
المصير للجنوبيين عندما اصبحوا اليوم في
سده السلطه التفوا على هذا الحق الذي يرون
انه مقدمه لتفتيت وتفكيك البلاد هؤلاء لي
محمد لا تعتقد انه كان من الاجد عفن سيدي
محمد الا تعتقد انه كان من الاجد النزول
عند رغبه الحوثيين في اعاده مناقشه مسوده
الدستور واعاده النظر بتقسيم الاقاليم
السته ولماذا الاصرار على هذا الموضوع
الذي يتخذه الحوثيون ذريعه للتمدد كما
تقول الى باقي مؤسسات واجهزه
الدوله يا سيدي العزيز دعني اضرب لك مثلا
دينيا بنو اسرائيل عندما قيل لهم اذبحوا
بقره دخلوا فيها شروط غير متناهيه من اجل
ان يتملص الدستور هو بقره بني اسرائيل
الحوثيين الدستور ليس العبره اذا حلت
مساله الدستور ستكون هناك قضايا اخرى يا
سيدي الكريم الحوثيون يبرعون في تبني
القضايا والمعاذير والحجج التي يتملصون
بها من الاتفاقات الدستور مصاغ ومتفق عليه
في خلال تسعه شهور من مؤتمر الحوار الوطني
ونتائجه صيغت في هذه وثيقه وثيقه الحوار
التي استخلص منها النص الدستوري والحوثيون
موجودون صباح مساء اثناء مناقشه هذه
المواد التي خرج بها الحوار الوطني لن
يعدم الحوثيون حتى لو حلت هذه الاشكاليه
في الدستور اليمني لن يعدموا مساله اخرى
وقضيه اخرى وعذرا اخر من اجل ان يسوف
ويماطل يا رجل الحوثيون اتوا بزعماء
الاحزاب السياسيه من اجل ان يوقعوا على
اتفاق السل والشراك الذي فصل لصالحهم
واليوم يقول ضيفك من صنعاء انهم انقلبوا
على هذا الاتفاق والاتفاق يطالب الحوثيين
بالانسحاب من العاصمه و ينسحب انما
زول سيدي محمد اريد ان اختم مع السيد علي
الفقيه باختصار شديد سيد علي ماذا تتوقع
على الصعيد الامني والسياسي هل نحن امام
انهيار واضح لاتفاق السلم والشراكه
وانهيار لكل ما يمكن ان يمسك بالوضع
الامني في
اليمن اعتقد ان اتفاق المشركه بدا في
الانهيار منذ ان تملص الحوثيون من النقطه
التي تلزمهم بسحب مليشياتهم والتوقف عن
اجتياح المدن فبعد حوالي اسبوع او اكثر من
اتفاق السلم والشراكه اتجه الحوثيون
بمليشيات جن جنوبا واستولوا على مدن وا
اسقطوا ادارات امن واسقطه معسكرات
وبالتالي الاوضاع الامنيه تتدهور واتفاق
السلم والشراكه منهار من ذلك الوقت لانهم
اول من تملص من هذا الاتفاق ورفض بنودا
كثيره تلزمهم هم يتابعون البنود التي تلزم
الاطراف الاخرى بينما يتملصون من اي بند
يخصهم او او تنفيذه يعنيهم ويعني توقفهم
عن الاجتياح وعن التوسع وعن السيطره على
المؤسسات التي بيديها القرار ا اشكرك
جزيلا عل الفقير رئيس تحرير صحيفه المصدر
المستقله من صنعاء واشكر من ليفربول
الكاتب والبحث السياسي اليمني محمد جميح
وطبعا الشكر موصول لعلي القحوم عضو المجلس
السياسي لجماعه انصار الله حدثنا عبر
الهاتف من صعدا بهذا مشاهدينا تنتهي
حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
للمتابعه والى اللقاء باذن
[موسيقى]
الله